so do you ever feel right
do you ever worried are you ever worried
that someone will look over one of your
old bits and go whoa
that's a bit naughty
and then try and start something or
cancel you do you know what I mean do
you ever worry about that yeah I do
sometimes I think everybody listens to
their old stuff though and is kind of
unimpressed by it in some ways because
you're evolving yeah unimpressed is
different though brother because if if
you are unimpressed if I'm unimpressed
with something you've done I'm not going
to come after you and try and ruin your
career right but for some people if
that's what I think he's getting at
which is like are you worried that
people you know you said the wrong thing
which wasn't even the wrong thing back
then and now it is and people are going
to come after you or is that not a
concern for you I don't I don't think
it's not a concern but I think I don't
think anybody could realistically look
at me
and think that I've
never said the wrong thing
you know what I'm saying like I know
what you say to be honest with you
you know right I was right yeah I mean I
was raised in the breadth of the wrong
thing you know so I've heard all of its
songs yeah right
um but do you think that makes you a
better comic feel like in the UK we've
got this generation of very like Rich
Posh middle class you know uh went to
Oxford and Cambridge you know they're
very smart comedians do you sometimes
think that the way you grew up the fact
you come from such a poor background
that just makes you funnier that
adversity that stuff you came through
um
yeah I think it get well yeah you gotta
have more the worst [__] is
the thing you know when
the word if you don't have any and this
wasn't us but this is just like a
hypothetical thing if you don't have any
like
like laughter will keep you warm you
know it's like so if you don't have
anything poor people sit around they're
more connected you know uh there's not
as much Sheltering from the world
there's not any like Hedges or any Gates
all your shit's hanging out the window
it's like so you're more like
um
these things just are a lot more real
right it's hard to hide being poor is
pretty hard to hide you know and so uh
yeah and poor people are outdoors more
they just hang out outside more and So
you you're talking with people and
laughing people are going to want to
laugh so you start laughing more
um so that's I think a lot of that just
makes sense like we hung outside a lot
you know maybe just as kids but also
parents were out there smoking and they
had some people were
um
what do you call it pedophiles and they
had
um you know people that have pedophiles
out there trying to [__] hang out
with you and [__] and so like
everybody's Milling around and it's just
like it's a good
soup to [__] you know make dumplings
out of you know so it's a good soup to
make humor out of you know really yeah
because when you got everything right
there all the ingredients it's just it's
a great time to pull jokes you know
so I missed that's some of the stuff
that I miss is just the reality was
right there all the time you know and
it's fun that was funny yeah uh it was
fun yeah and does does the life of
stand-up does that make you happy you
enjoy it
well it's interesting because it gets
pretty Lonesome as it you get more
successful in some ways yeah yeah yeah
it does it gets pretty Lonesome I think
in some ways
um but give us an example well like you
go to the audience now if you have a
bigger audience right you go there to a
theater and you go out and they come in
from this way and you come in from the
back and you kind of meet along this
line at the stage and there's not really
any co-mingling and then you both go
your separate ways you know whereas I
think with the clubs it used to feel a
little bit more like involved and you
and your buddies were always there
together but once you kind of go out
touring and you know kind of make your
way and find your success in it which is
awesome you uh you kind of have to be
it's not lonely but you a lot of that is
time you know with just you so I think
you have to learn to bring like your
mates along and your teammates or
whatever and um whatever you know if you
bring animal or whatever if you bring it
you know snacks or animals or whatever
some people bring a lot of the same
thing yeah yeah yeah I guess
I guess man but that's interesting
yeah it's it's been interesting man yes
I don't know what we're supposed to be
talking about exactly there's nothing
that was okay we're just having a
conversation yeah yeah is this but you
guys are like detectives huh yeah do we
feel like detectives a little bit a
little bit is this uncomfortable for you
no I don't think so I don't know
so but I don't feel like it is that much
maybe some moments okay yeah because I
but what we're trying to get to the
heart I I guess and we're trying to
understand Theo is just like what makes
you tick what makes you tick the way you
work yeah and what like I guess yeah I
mean you guys are kind of like
um
it's like uh unfairness Hunters Maybe
does it feel like that is that what you
think yeah yeah how so like unfairness
Hunters like you hunt down things that
seem unfair
you know what that's a good description
yeah is it yeah is it fair or no I think
that's a fair description yeah yeah I
like that I like things to try and be
fair you know yeah and it's hard to
equivocate that or figure that out yeah
right it's hard to figure it out so I
think you have to have people that are
hot on the case you know that's a good
description that's a really really good
description man yeah uh yeah and we're
not trying to start any [__] I'm just
we're just curious about how people see
the world and from our perspective we
you know we we both come from
backgrounds where we feel fairness is
important people not being mistreated is
important you know people not being
picked on on the because of the way they
grew up or what their skin color is or
whatever yeah you know either way black
or white doesn't really matter right
um yeah it was yeah I mean like there's
never like the
when it came to like black white stuff
it always felt like it was the white
person's fault even if right you felt
like you know because the in our town
black people were having a tougher time
overall yeah you know and so
um you know a lot of times I feel like
they got the benefit of it out from
people maybe from authorities and stuff
they didn't I don't know what you know
that's like I just have only been just
me
um that's interesting that you say that
because like in the UK like we talk a
lot about like white privilege and look
if you've if you've come for money and
you're white you're definitely
privileged but there's loads of places
in the UK which is just like the places
that you grew up in like where these
people legitimately have nothing they've
got nothing you know and every day for
them is a struggle and then for people
to come along and go you're privileged
to me
you know right well yeah it's crazy
you're like oh well if I am at least
give me some of it yeah you know yeah
it's crazy man I think but also it's
like a lot of the people that say that
they they've never they're not from
those places no they've never been there
they don't know what it's like you know
a lot of people like in like
in Los Angeles you know a lot in some of
the community they
they didn't know what's even none of
them could even relate to anything I was
talking about because they just didn't
know it you know they were all like it
was mostly people from uh New York or LA
or Boston you know and it was more like
uh just from a different kind of class
of society sometimes not always but
maybe that's going to start changing too
I think if there's less uh
if a lot like that overtly woke
programming kind of goes numb eventually
that will have to evolve because I don't
think that the entertainment industry
really has any
couth I don't know if that's the word or
not what does that mean I don't know
what it means I don't know what it means
do you mean like Cloud do you mean like
the entertainment industry is dying no I
think but they don't have any real
like
moral compass I don't think yeah or
maybe that's not it that's [__] crazy
no no no just talk about that small
that's interesting but they well no no
this is what it is they just follow
where the money goes yeah yeah that's it
okay so I think it's work we go this way
tomorrow it's not work we go that way
right